hey guys it's mkbhd and welcome to a
video of all you need to know about
YouTube's brand new video editor now
I've already seen a basic video editor
from YouTube before you can click the
annotation to view that but this one's a
little bit different not only because of
the new features but it has one key
difference when you're done editing in
this one and save your effects the video
stays online as the same video so no
more republishing or reesh airing a new
video this one has all the likes views
and comments of the original on eligible
videos you'll see a Save button click
the save not save as and this lets you
retain everything so it's really nice so
here's the layout of the editor itself
pretty sweet to pain view on the left
hand side is the original on the right
is the new video which may look a little
bit grainy in the preview but that's
okay because when you save it it keeps
full quality and up here at the top of
your 3 tabs quick fixes video effects
and audio the first two of the quick
fixes we've seen before in the old
YouTube editor you can trim the awkward
parts of the video with you turning your
camera on and off and if you're absurd
enough to film upside down or sideways
oh you can fix that here too and last
but not least we have this really neat
stabilization button I wasn't sure it
would work well but I intentionally
filmed shaky video as you can tell in
the preview windows and this after
processes actually works amazingly well
now I do have to note that it did
actually zoom into my video just a
little bit to cut out the edges which
would have been moving but I don't know
if it'll do that to every video but so
far it looks like it's a pretty useful
feature for those of you filming you
know casual stuff anyway over here on
the right hand side we have all of our
lighting stuff which will basically make
the video look different if you have
that lucky button it'll try to figure it
out for you but I wouldn't exactly
recommend that either way the options
you have starts with fill light which
lets you artificially add light to your
video then you have contrast which will
separate darks from lights more or less
next you have saturation which will
increase or decrease color intensity and
finally there's color temperature and
drag towards the red to make it look
like you filmed on the Sun and dragged
towards blue to give it a little cool
hue next you have the effects tab which
is again really basic and meant for
beginners who don't have a video editor
yet so this isn't going to replace your
iMovie or moviemaker or anything but
it's nice to see and it does give you a
few cool options to add some neat
extra videos when you hit that apply
button just give it a second to process
and it'll go ahead and apply the effect
to your video and you can watch it right
in the preview pane I'll let you go
ahead off on your own and play with
those effects so you can take a look at
them but just so you know right now
there are about a dozen of them but I
can expect YouTube to add a few more
later but that's basically it for the
effects tab the last section is kind of
boring it's an audio tab but it's the
same thing that lets you you know pick
music to play over your video nothing
really you know new here something
interesting though is they let you pick
the audio based on how long your video
is so they can match up in time and
nothing gets cut off so I you know it's
nice that they let you have that option
you can also search tracks but you know
nothing really groundbreaking or new
here finally when you're done with all
this editing and you're satisfied with
your bang and new video you can go up
and hit that Save button and it'll begin
to process your new video and when it's
done the video will return live with the
same URL as before same like same
comments all the stuff still there so
boom you win so that's basically it guys
for the Video Editor what do you think
of it you like it if this tutorial
helped you out at all be sure to
subscribe for more thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you later peace